a mass Exodus out of New York and
there's a mass uh migration to Florida
they say just in the first quarter 10
000 people swapped their New York State
IDs for Florida IDs New York's in a
state of decay hasn't happened since
covet there was there's hundreds of
hundreds of thousands all of these all
of these Democrat cities are just
ripping themselves apart they vote blue
and then they don't like the policies
and they leave but but it's it's it's
remarkable that there is no way in my
mind the mayor you know people like de
Blasio and now Adams that the mayor's or
or you know who who's the current mayor
of LA but you had I think was Garcetti
during a lockdown there's no way they
did not know what they were doing like I
just don't Gavin Newsom for instance he
goes to Florida do you guys see this
video yeah he goes to Florida and he
says authoritarian regime DeSantis
Banning books he knows he's lying like
there's no way he actually believes the
things he says which means the only
conclusion is they're all evil he was
arresting people for running running
businesses for heaven a restaurant that
was open he was arresting people just
for trying to live and survive in the
state of California and he has the balls
to go to Florida and say Santa says it's
a what I mean it's just so on your face
it's so ridiculous that that is I gotta
say though guys insane if you're aware
of what's going on then you've already
started making your plans to get away
from these cities you've left these
cities you've maybe gone to Florida or
Texas or a rural area you've perhaps
purchased some chickens which are now
creating more of themselves it's a
really amazing thing they do not only do
they make food for you but that food
could actually turn into more of them
which can then make more exponentially
so you're aware of what's going on
you're protecting yourself you're
learning you're having a family you're
taking your kids out of school the end
result of this is the policies enacted
by democrats is just causing harm to
their own constituents They are
promoting policies that sterilize their
constituents that cause their
constituents to abort and destroy their
own children and then they bring about
corruption in their cities it's almost
like this imagine there was a civil war
happening imagine there was an actual
Civil War and it was Republican versus
Democrats left versus right
I couldn't ask of anything more of
Democrats right if you're if you're on
the right and you are like we are going
to war here's my plan we will infiltrate
the seats of government in our opponents
cities and then enact policies that will
erode and destroy those cities and cause
their citizens to flee to us then we
will control like they're
self-destructing themselves and it all
like if you could if you told me what
happened was Republicans infiltrated
Democrat cities to destroy them I'd be
like well they're doing a good job of it
I can't see I why else would they do
these things that's my point Gavin
Newsom knows he's lying he knows he's
destroying things you can't look at that
they have a map you can look up for San
Francisco that shows you where all the
poop is I'm not exaggerating it's true
that's true it's like someone took
Google Google Maps and then they made uh
you know you could do a plug-in or
whatever yeah the heat is emitting no it
shows a little brown brown uh pins it's
like ways you tag it there's brown paper
you tag it yes and so what happens is
someone when they see poop they'll they
will write down the address and put it
in the map and so the whole of San
Francisco is one it's it's all brown
because every inch of it is covered in
these pins
Gavin Newsom Nancy Pelosi these people
know that that that that is a problem
they don't care this is the part they do
nothing to stop it I get start to get
nauseous at this part of the
conversation because I had a crazy dream
last night a crazy dream but I was the
president and we were like we did it we
finally did it let's go we're gonna go
sign the let's go sign the paperwork in
your office and we I walk into my office
and a guy points a gun at me and shoots
me in the heart like as I walked in you
cannot defeat the military-industrial
complex it cannot be stopped so it's
either get along or throw your body away
is where I'm at other than that I'm just
like let's just jam and make some hot
music and maybe we can convince
everybody that way because even Cloud
Schwab Likes music they have those weird
singers that those weird musicians
when that happened the guy shot me in
the heart I said this is a dream and
it's my dream so I'm rewinding this and
then I went back and got the guy's name
and it started with an S uh it was a
very very disconcerting dream and it led
me to think that if I pursue the
political solution I will be offed by
the by the system but there are other
ways to solve this and a lot of it is
local governance and taking care of your
family and your neighborhood but I think
you need to be aggressively creative I
think that's a bit for me anyway that's
my path
I agree with you on that there's a lot
the political stuff you know they're all
Liars but if you actually just
start with loving your neighbor just
start at home that's a bloody good start
and if everyone just started at home
thinking who Who's On My Street who can
I help let's do this let's look after
our family that's how you actually
defeat it the opposite and forgive me if
I get a bit churchy Lads but the
opposite of all this stuff or stuff is
it's the church it's scripture it's the
Bible that's literally the opposite
that's how you defeat it but yeah I mean
no you're not changing anybody's mind if
you can't have a good relationship with
your family at home on Thanksgiving
dinner it's like being able to have
conversations at home with your parents
who you completely disagree with like
you have to have that skill you're
doomed without it and no one can there's
so many people who are abandoning their
parents you know just you know talk of
like trying to do all this change
politics you're you're absolutely right
though let's start by make amends with
your family that since 2016 you're not
able to have Thanksgiving anymore
because they've got what the wrong
opinion like one's a tough oh no the
ones work oh no actually maybe try mend
that first worry about politics
here's the issue though uh Jack euger
had a masterful tweet today and many
people listening may be gasping or
spitting out their water having heard me
say that he said that I'll paraphrase
the right is willing to accept anyone
who agrees so much as five percent with
them whereas the left will excise anyone
who disagrees with 0.05 percent of their
position and he's completely correct The
Young Turks are getting have been
relentlessly slammed because Anna
kasparian said don't call me a birthing
person I bring this up because you're
talking about you know mending that
divide and everything but I got to tell
you man I think a lot of people listen
have have tried to be that reasonable
person talking to someone who is woke or
in the cult and saying something as
simple as like well let's talk about it
and they just get angry and say no yeah
you gotta make them the center of
attention it's kind of like you gotta
let them be selfish for a moment a lot
of people in the not just a moment it
can take years but it's it's it's it's
the issue is it's worth it if you have
if you have a a relative who is a Turf
you know that's a trans-exclusionary
radical feminist I I want to point this
out by the way they call anyone who is
like against gender ideology a Turf even
if they're not feminists like
these conservative women are not
feminists okay so don't call them that
but I call them something else but uh my
point is this if I I guarantee you 100
if you sit down with someone who is
described as a turf they're going to
have a conversation with you about what
they think and why they think it if you
sit down with someone who we would
describe as woke 95 of the time they
will get emotional angry and reject the
the the argument outright or just refuse
to sit down with you at all in those
situations I find if you can stay calm
it's kind of like it erodes their anger
uh it takes time and patience but if
someone's freaking out and you stay calm
the entire it's it's it's contagious no
it makes them really angry actually at
First maybe well this is this is like a
common well-known thing in in debate
that if your opponent is getting
flustered and you lower your tone and
get more calm they get it actually in
inverts and makes them angrier but the
Assumption you're making is that the
conversation you're having is about the
politics or about the philosophy what
about actually trying to regain remember
all those other things that we have in
common and maybe just let's not talk
about politics for a couple years let's
just remember there are more important
things than politics importance as
politics are important as these issues
are on a family level okay let's do
let's talk about let's talk about
Football let's talk about some of those
deeper things well let me let me give
you scenario then and ask your thoughts
on this I brought this up a couple weeks
ago when I was hanging out in a poker
room and the guy on my left were playing
a table it's a nine nine player game
funny guy we are laughing having a good
time whenever you play at these tables
your side of the tables are whispering
to each other the other side's
whispering and we got this guy who is
bluffing like crazy so the dude to my
lap starts making some jokes I'm
laughing with him he's nudging me and
saying look what he's doing and we're ha
ha ha ha
then politics comes up because of the
economy naturally when you're playing a
game that involves money and it got to
the point where he said that he thought
the January 6th defendant should all be
executed for treason
and I'm like okay here's a guy who is
laughing with me we're having a good
time man we're almost friends and then
he says something as terrifying as that
how am I supposed to like I'll be honest
this guy was telling me a story about a
dude who was criminally charged because
uh antifa surrounded his car he fled and
then got charged with attempted murder
because he hit people as he was fleeing
and so I was like you should put me in
touch with this guy like let's talk and
he goes yeah it's BS what they did to
this guy and I'm like okay so me and
this guy got something to agree on and
maybe we can solve these issues
and and I would say the majority of our
interaction was not political at all the
moment he said he wanted he believed
that they should execute these guys I'm
like
I don't think so in that scenario you
don't have you're not going to actually
achieve anything by talking about that
which is why I try to persuade it so
what you can just do is ask them loads
of questions try and work out why it is
that he's come to that conclusion and
maybe in asking the questions that he
hasn't been asked by anyone because he
hasn't met someone with different
political positions or different
opinions he might go home and be like
you know what maybe I was a bit wrong on
that you don't have to you don't have to
persuade him in the moment just ask him
the question because by the way it's
also interesting like an extremist like
that like how do you come to that that's
quite interesting and this is this is
like a regular guy I think he said he
worked construction who's playing a game
of poker having a laugh on his day off
and then all of a sudden he says
something as Extreme as that and that
was like he's probably just
regurgitating it from you know he got a
circle
this is the thing like he got so angry
about it is why I was just like okay
like I'm gonna I'm Gonna Leave This guy
be because you know I I asked him when
he said that I was like really executed
wow he said it in a different way I'll
mind you he said in a very very gruesome
and graphic way to put it simply and uh
my response was uh did you hear about
what happened on May 29th with the the
the the left is the White House and he
goes no I don't think about that and I
was like they they set St John's Church
on fire and they you know the pr Trump
was forced into bunker he goes I don't
know what you're talking about these
people I'm telling you it's they were
traitors and I'm just like I'm done I'm
not I mean he's invented well because
now he might a month later he might have
his brain perhaps and he'll have to deal
with that and I'm sure there'll be
cognitive dissonance and and might he
might have to do that unpacking by
himself and it might be quite painful
for that fella to do that unpacking but
you might have planted the seed I think
that's the correct way to deal with it
or or you doubled down on his extremism
go even further
it's a plan maybe we should maybe we
should treat their children just like
Barack Obama treated the children in the
Middle East and bombed them during their
wedding that's that actually is so that
is a persuasion technique I have talked
about before it's called Rapport extreme
turn where in order to change someone's
mind you have to approach them from
further than their own position so it's
it's a really basic manipulation
technique the general idea is for the
first thing if someone presents to you
an idea that you disagree with the first
thing is Rapport you completely agree
with it now in their minds this lowers
their defenses and they feel like you're
part of their same tribe the second is
the extreme like Luke said you double
down and go further than they would find
reasonable forcing them in the other
direction yeah it shows them where they
may end up if they stay on the path of
extremism you're like okay I see where
what you mean or just how ridiculous
this is or just this question their
original stance it's actually much
simpler than that you make yourself
their ideological opponent in the other
direction which forces them in your
direction you know I have friends that
say kind of stuff like your that guy you
were talking about Tim just weird
extreme things about racism like friends
from over the years and I realized like
I can handle in a conversation and you
can easily ask questions and get past it
and find out the psychology but when
people post those things on social media
in text they get ripped out of context
and hot the person for their entire not
the medium the texts social media
absolutely not the medium if you can't
avoid doing it I think it has to be the
best face to face but even a phone call
is better you just there's so much in
tone you lose Friends by text if you
have those conversations I've actually
written off talking about politics and
text that's a wise principle to I have I
think it's it's helpful well it's
similar to how like if you're walking
down the street in New York City and you
see people handing out propaganda or you
know just crazy people mouthing off like
people will just walk by crazy people in
New York City they're not they wouldn't
ask them to get banned from the street
corner necessarily but if you see a
social media post you go completely
insane wow so
let me I'll tell you I'll tell you
another story I was in I think Luke was
actually there uh uh I think you are I'm
not sure we were in New York during a
stop fascism protest you're probably
there because you're at I'm always yeah
yeah you're at everything on that and
I'm not everything in Europe uh it was a
it was it was called like refuse fascism
or something like this it's an
organization associated with revcom
revolutionary communists and so I see
this woman I'm just out there filming
and I'm like just seeing what's up I
can't I think this might have been like
2017 or 2018. I see this woman holding a
sign that says stop fascism or whatever
and I'm filming so I say ma'am is it all
right if I'm I'm doing a live stream is
it okay if I ask you some questions and
she's like yes of course and you wanna
just explain uh you know why you came
out today and what your sign means and
then she's like yes you know I think
blah Blanche explains all this stuff and
then I said uh you know
I forgot how I said it but I was very
much just like some of the activists
here that have organized this are with
an organization called revcom I'm
curious if you are here just for stop
fascism or refuse fascism or if you
actually came out with the Revolutionary
Communist party and she snapped started
screaming at me calling me Fox News but
what I said was a legitimate question
that was true revcom was there they were
the ones that gave her the sign she was
waving their sign and when I simply
asked her I was like did you come out
here in support of them or is it just
about fascism she snapped and started
screaming and totally shut down no more
logical discussion I couldn't even get a
regular question at that point so there
are people who are like
I don't know what it is you know and I
was just like I'm sorry for asking it is
best to start with your family people
that you have something in contact with
and then it's kind of like training a
muscle I think you mentioned that
earlier bill it's like a it's like a
skill you need to have to succeed in
life is to be able to ask questions to
probe
things you disagree with and genuinely
listen to that empathize with people
um well because the moment you have to
disattach from an outcome of changing
their mind exactly exactly if you want
to do that then people can sense it and
even if they want to agree with you they
won't agree with you if they feel like
you're trying to pressure them into
thinking what they thought they might
double down if they feel pressured so
that's what happened to Kanye well so
wanted to double down because he's fed
up with everyone telling him you can't
think that so this is this is the issue
with many things the basic manipulation
right I've talked about this a lot over
the years
um because I used to hang out at
hackerspace is social engineering is
like a principal uh subset of the hacker
community of hacker of I don't know
whatever you call it
whenever you hear about a big story
about someone getting hacked it's
usually social engineering the
manipulation of a human being into
giving up access or information or
something like that and in that you
learn a lot about this stuff here's the
challenge I find
knowing how to manipulate someone's
position I find to be the dark side
actively going to someone and then
pulling off that trick or poor extreme
turn to me is evil you are you are
tricking someone into doing something
that you want them to do I believe the
good thing to do is provide them with an
opportunity and information and be a
reasonable understanding human being and
let them be a free individual who
decides for themself the problem the
other side uses those technique
techniques on regular people and that's
why it's so difficult hence why you you
see things like with uh Kyle Rittenhouse
for instance the media lies the
Covington kids the media lies Jesse
Smollett they lie we hear I I always
look at it like this we've decided to
play a game of Monopoly the left and the
right and we are watching the left pull
bills out of the bank and they just keep
saying what are you going to do about it
and we're like guess I'll just keep
playing can't understand why I keep
losing though that's the challenge the
the you know there's the there's
different modes for it right because
there's the there's the dinner table
where where you should go into the
conversation thinking I might actually
learn something they might be right
about something that I'm wrong about
which by the way for the din table is an
important person's coming and then
there's the political level and I I
don't think it's right to conflate the
two because it's a different you should
have a different mindset going into both
agreed agree yeah so you think that game
theory playing it out you know good
faith and bad faith bad faith will
eventually Stomp over the good faith I
mean
I don't know if it's allude but I'll put
it this way if uh if you're gonna go if
you and Ian we're gonna race a foot race
you know 100 meter sprint or something
and Ian's wearing rollerblades are you
gonna be like I might be able to win
this one I mean honestly I don't know
you might be able to yeah
and and I say it's been about 30 years
and he's got a hundred millimeter Wheels
they're real big real fast I played
hockey I would kill you okay you're like
let's race and he's riding a bike you're
like okay like how am I supposed to win
this if you're riding a bike and I'm
running and I'm trying to be honest and
you're cheating I think if people know
that they're being cheated or that
they're using some dark energy to
convince them then they will revolt and
embrace the light side but if they don't
know that's when the dark will overcome
then then maybe the simple thing is not
to argue with people about their
political perspective but to show them
an instance where the media lied and
that's just about it meaning so you can
ask them be like oh yeah tell me about
that I no I genuinely want to hear more
and then when they say something that is
you know to be factually false you can
go you can say something like oh wasn't
no I heard about that one pull it up on
your phone and be like I think that's no
I think that one wasn't true and shown
and be proactive don't wait because I
had a conversation with my mom about
Robert F Kennedy Jr who she loves and is
always loved and I was like really early
on I said get ready watch what the media
is going to do because they I saw two
articles where they said anti-vaxx right
she's like yeah yeah but if I'd waited
six months to have that conversation
she'd already be indoctrinated by that
media so I was able to kind of
cut it off at the at the turn kind of
wrapped it yeah like get ready that you
might see some subterfuge coming were
you about maybe it's as simple as just
like when you're at the dinner table you
can be like I don't want to argue you
know you're probably right about a whole
bunch of stuff can I just show you this
one thing and then show them like where
the media lied in a modern instance
about something significant and then be
like I'm not here to tell you what to
think what to believe I just want you to
see this the crazy thing is the left
accuses the media of lying all the time
but for some reason they March in
lockstep with these narratives because
this is the challenge I I think that's
why I call it a cult you know how do you
break someone from a cult here's the
real challenge I think we have
the reason why they are likely not going
to care about your arguments we're
approaching this and I think this is
unfortunate but we approach this from
our personal biases which is you know we
think we can have a reason discussion
with someone perhaps planting the seed
of an idea may change their mind but
what's being omitted from that concept
that conversation is that these people
are seeking only likes and retweets
that's it they don't care about whether
or not they're proving something to be
true or solving a problem they care if
they get social gratification again
you're now in the Twitter medium right
and you're this is like social media as
we as we discussed these all of these
distant scenarios uh when I went on
different behavioral right right what I
mean though is it's not I'm I'm using
social media as the vehicle to explain
the average person who sits down like
let's say you sit down with your family
members there's a reason why they hold
these views it's because you are the
summation of The Five People You
surround yourself with they're not going
to want to agree with you they will
reject what you say because in three
hours they will once again be surrounded
by cult members who will reinforce all
of their thinking and they will reject
what you said the the challenge is how
do you get someone out of a cult add a
top layer to that their phones keep them
connected to the cult 24 7. what do you
do I think that the likes and shares is
kind of an empty purpose it's definitely
there's a you know there's some there's
something to getting rich but
being being listened to is I think more
fulfilling than getting 100 likes so
that's why verbalizing and listening is
so important with family and friends I I
do think it's it's I I think there are a
lot of regular people who believe false
things and they're not woke right
there's a thing too uh I will say fair
point to Winston in that a lot of the
context of what I'm talking about
specifically refers to people who are
politically initiated but there are a
lot of people who I would refer to as
uninitiated who believe what we it's
what Andrew Breitbart called default
liberal who will be willing to listen to
things even if they're a little hostile
at first because it sounds foreign to
them but eventually will be a lot you
know you're right about that you know
it's it that is to say the left wins a
lot because regular people who don't pay
attention will just vote their way
because they don't pay attention and if
we do speak to many of these people and
we are calm and reasonable we end up
finding that maybe it's only 10 20 or 30
percent of these people aren't actually
indoctrinated aren't actually woke they
just don't know anything at all
absolutely I think that's I in fact that
would have been the case for me and I
can think of examples in my history
where I just had default normally
positions without having really thought
about them and then when someone
challenged me and I actually thought
about it that's when I changed my mind I
think you're absolutely right people go
along with it yeah I wonder if we had
that moment with uh for those who saw
the member segment when I was ranting
about Ukraine with Dr Peter pogosian
I'll just say Man the War stuff triggers
me that's if if like the one thing that
takes me from calm to like cranked up to
11 is people trying to justify foreign
intervention and War and all that stuff
they'll use it against you or just
blowing people up and murdering inside
human beings that that is the epitome of
absolute just immoral wrong on unless
Earth there's nothing that gets me
angrier than people who support say like
what you want you want to trigger me
come up to me and ignorantly just try to
justify the war in Ukraine without
knowing anything about it and I'm just
gonna be like
you're out of your mind do you ever use
other tactics to manipulate them I know
it sounds cold but like I'll just have a
straightforward argument and if they if
they don't like you know when I used to
do the nonprofit fundraising it was all
pure manipulation they trained you to
manipulate they tell you to manipulate
and then eventually it's just like this
is not good like going out and
convincing people to be part of a cause
by tricking them is not a good thing and
I and I don't want to be part of that
okay what's I mean sorry here's a
question so if you're saying that you
should not be able to be pro-war in the
in Ukraine or whichever War without
being knowledgeable about it do you also
think that you should not be able to be
anti-war in Ukraine without being
knowledgeable about it so anti-war it's
okay to not be knowledgeable yes okay
yes simply put if you're saying hey I
would like to uh blow up this this other
this far away land it's like well look I
gotta be honest I don't know anything
about that so I'm going to air on the
side if we shouldn't blow people up
until proven guilty yeah yeah if you
can't provide me with a justification
for why you're blowing people up I'm not
going to agree with you on it but I mean
look people who watch the show know me
I'm they call me milk toast fence sitter
as kind of like and and the origin of
that is someone commented on a video
calling me that and I totally went with
it I was like yes absolutely because
there's too much I don't know so I'm not
going to come out and be like this is
definitively true it's like well
honestly I don't know I mean if if I see
a video of it happening
I'll I'll be more inclined to believe it
and say hey look there's a video of this
Democrat guy attacking people he was
criminally charged for doing it stands
to reason it's likely true but for all I
know is a guy wearing a mask I don't
know you know pretending to be him I
really doubt it the you know Occam's
razor suggests this dude was attacking
people but I'm not I'm not gonna just
come out and be like everyone else that
it's true therefore it is you know yeah
there's so much media manipulation it
seems like our goal our job I can't
speak for everyone but is to keep people
calm is to like create like a spiritual
realm that we can all coexist in maybe
it's just mine I don't know you have a
great opportunity you like bring Intel
like intellect or like bring information
to people that I appreciate I like to
make people calm while they learn the
information but I'm less focused on the
actual information more on how you feel
when you learn it well a lot of people
are being Hoodwinked they're being
conned there's so much emotional
manipulation there's so many psyops and
and I wish people would just realized
your neighbor is not your enemy the the
Republican down the street is not trying
trying to hurt you or kill you but they
have convinced so many human beings that
that the person opposite of you living
next to you or might believe something
politically is somehow your greatest
danger to your existence that's not true
and I think it's solely done on purpose
so we don't realize who is or what is
the purpose and and the reason why
people are suffering and dealing with so
much pain and grief and and pain and
suffering in their life uh and and when
you truly do kind of look at it I I
think one of the biggest Solutions is
just being the best version of yourself
being personally responsible being happy
and being healthy and I think doing
those things is a modern day Act of
resistance against our modern system in
modern society which thrives off of
negativity and hatred and and bigotry
and just ignorance and I think the more
we strive to be better the more we
Inspire others to do the same and I
think the small decisions forget about
trying to change other people change
yourself try to make yourself the best
version of yourself try to make yourself
an individual who doesn't buy in to the
psyops doesn't buy the bull crap doesn't
give your money to those evil beings
those evil creatures those entities and
demons that of course Thrive off of
screwing you over and I and I think if
we really kind of self-reflect more that
would be a lot better than just being
like you do what I want you to do and I
think we need more yeah Luke man you put
your money where your mouth is because
that that event today that Gathering was
incredible it just there's a power of
meeting with other like-minded
individuals just like the event that you
know you guys are putting on tomorrow
and and Bill you're putting on Saturday
there's a power with individuals coming
together there's an energy there there's
a frequency there uh and you know we
could get all hippie dippy but there's a
congruence there is a combining of those
energies that is very powerful this is
why we are starting we are we are
launching a coffee shop
it's going to be in West Virginia the
plans have already been drawn up the
contractor has been contracted and we're
preparing plumbing and all that stuff
the idea that we had was you want to
solve these problems a lot of ways you
can do it you can have a family you can
have kids you can get away from cities
homeschool your kids all that good stuff
that's a powerful thing you can do right
now and don't forget don't buy Bud Light
or Anheuser-Busch products now the other
thing we're doing I hope my vision in
five years 50 coffee shops around the
United States in or in in in semi-urban
maybe Suburban areas cast brew coffee
when you walk in the front door and you
walk up to the counter to buy coffee
there's a little seating area and
there's a TV with Stephen Crowder
playing on it there's a TV with Viva and
Barnes with 6X and Hammer with Tim cast
IRL with we are change and people will
walk in and they'll be sitting down and
they'll be sitting their coffee and
they'll be looking up and they'll just
possibly be watching these shows we do
that we launch a thousand of these
coffee shops we start franchising them
and then we put our perspectives in
shopping centers the other component is
to start once we get this one up and
running we'll uh the first thing I'm
going to do is investigate franchising
because that's probably the fastest and
easiest way to make these things exist
everywhere I don't need to be the CEO of
a massive multinational corporation of
you know of coffee shops I want coffee
shops to exist where like-minded
individuals can come get together and
have a cup of coffee and we can
guarantee the expansion of ideas like
ours or Crowders or Luke's Etc and and
all of the minds creators who are coming
to the event on Saturday people like
that no it's amazing that you're
starting coffee shop because coffee
coffee shops there's actually research
around this led to the age of
enlightenment boom look I mean not even
joking like yes there's Empirical
research that people people come
together in coffee houses and this is
like the breeding grounds of Korea what
we'll do is next we'll buy the building
next door and then we'll make
redkowski's burrito shop and then you
can get them a burrito the coffee for
your butt in the coffee for your mouth
sorry this is actually the reason real
quick okay the the second and third
floor of the building are our social
club so the second floor is going to be
a basic social hangout and the third
floor is going to be our members only
Social Club we're probably going to film
poker with the boys in this building on
the third floor where our top tier
members are able to actually hang out
the show is mostly just a table Talk
podcast meaning you get a handful of
people to hang out and I'll talk about
these issues and poker's a backdrop to
make it something more fun but then we
are going to have people come from all
over to hang out to meet each other to
share ideas and the goal is to build
community strengthen bonds between
people learn who our neighbors are share
our moral values and win a culture War
pierogies not tacos zooming out a little
bit and this is a conversation I've been
having in Britain with friends and and
like-minded people Eve the institutions
the corporations are all captured as we
believe they are by various ideologies
the response is that we need to build
our own Industries our own
infrastructure our own as you describe
uh businesses like this that are
widespread that is actually a great way
of defeating the ideological capture of
of uh so many Industries yep um I'm
really excited for the idea look if we
launch
uh franchises which I I expect we will
imagine this not only will we carry you
know our coffee brand but there's a
whole bunch of Jeremy's chocolate so uh
for our chocolate bars on the counter
for our impulse buys we'll get Jeremy
boring's uh you know chocolate brand if
we get a liquor license for upstairs
we'll have the conservative dads you
know uh Ultra right or whatever I have a
cigar business boom Winston cigars yeah
we're called 1573 which is the year that
tobacco first came to Britain might we
stock you yes yeah fantastic we'll we'll
have because especially if we're doing a
social club I don't know if we can
actually allow people to smoke in the
building you can get licenses we'll talk
later we'll figure out some cigars
because my man so uh when we were
talking about doing poker with the boys
obviously everyone asked can we smoke
cigars and I'm like I think the
challenge is like can you smoke indoors
and stuff but having a bunch of people
sitting around playing a game of poker
and smack talking and the the and I'll
stress this too the idea for the show
isn't actually about poker it's to have
a table with eight or nine people who
are all talking about various issues
with poker as kind of the through line
for everybody so you'll see some table
action and some some ribbing on each
other you have to be able to multitask
but it's good but you'll you'll get the
periodic you know like I was mentioning
that guy who mentioned was talking about
January 6th to meet the poker table that
stuff happens and these are really
interesting conversations when you get
random people who don't know each other
start talking about this stuff that'll
be fascinating but then you know they'll
light a cigar up we need to burn sticks
the problem you might have though is
that it's so ideologically in one way
that that you need to attract the people
who think differently how are we going
to do that it's a game of poker
but if you've got Crowder on the Telly
Oh you mean the coffee shops yeah this
is the point it's the Trojan Horse the
average person the Normie doesn't know
or care about Crowder and so they go to
their local shopping center where
they're picking up dog food and they're
like yeah I'm gonna grab a nice coffee
before I go home and then go uh oh
there's a coffee shop right there and
they walk in and they're like I'll do a
large iced coffee uh with you know half
and half and they're waiting and they
look over and there's the TV and they're
just watching and then they see Crowder
being like can you believe the Democrats
are doing this thing again and they're
just like huh thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time